لا أحد كل من لم يفعل هذه الحرب يوم 26
ولم يفعل ذلك في 28 ولا في 2010 ولا في 24
آمل أن يكون الأمر أسهل الآن، لسوء الحظ
لقد ظل الحاخام يقول هذا منذ 17 عامًا
سيكون الأمر أسهل، وسيكون هناك عدد أقل من الضحايا، وهذا ليس بالأمر السهل
هذه الحرب تمثل تحديًا لهذا البلد بأكمله
لفترة طويلة جدًا في اليوم الذي بدأ صباح السبت
في أكتوبر قلت من ثلاثة إلى ستة أشهر
سأطلب قريبًا تقديرًا وسيستغرق هذا الإصلاح وقتًا طويلاً
الوقت لماذا يوجد قتلى اليوم أكثر من الواقع
قبل فترة الهدوء لأنه إذا كان هناك المزيد من القتلى فأنا
لم أتحقق من ذلك ولكن إذا كان هناك المزيد من القتلى فهو كذلك
لا، ليس على الإطلاق بسبب الاستراحة، بل بسبب الحقيقة
الذي انتقل من منطقة القتال الحضري إلى منطقة
القتال أكثر انفتاحًا ونتيجة لذلك
هناك نطاقات أطول ليطلق عليها نانت
الإرهابيون هم أيضًا مراقبون ومن السهل التعرف عليهم
قواتنا تلك المناطق هي بيوت مفتوحة نسبيا
تلك التي تحتوي على طابق أو طابقين، لا أكثر من ذلك وخارجها
من ذلك كما
ومع تقدم القتال نتعلم الدروس أيضا ولكن
وللأسف فإن العدو أيضاً يتعلم الدروس وهو يعلم
التغلب على بعض نقاط القوة لدينا ومن ثم نحن
نحن بحاجة إلى إيجاد طريقة للتغلب على ما تغلب عليه
نعم، القتال صعب، وقتال العصابات بشكل عام صعب
الخدود الميتة لحرب العصابات بشكل عام لها ميزة
إلى الدرع لأنه ينبثق وهو يغير ملابسه فيرى
في الشارع مثل
مواطن وفجأة يسحب سلاحه ويغادر
من التفسير أعدل بكثير مما فعلناه ولكن
ما زلت أشاهد فيديوهات حماس ما
ما يثير القلق في فيديوهات حماس هو أن هذا هو الواقع
يتم دائمًا تدمير تنظيم الأفراد داخل المنازل
الطريقة التي يأسرون بها جنود جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي قوية جدًا جدًا
بالقرب منهم من الأماكن التي ليست بالضرورة الأكثر خصوبة
أنواع المباني التي لم يتم مسحها أو التي تم مسحها ووصلت
بالنسبة لهم ما يحدث في ثلاثة أحياء مشابه
وفي شمال قطاع غزة بيت ليا وبيت حالان أيضا
في الشجاعية أن الجيش الإسرائيلي يستعيد أماكنه
بعض المواطنين يقعون تحت هذا الغطاء
جميع أنواع الرجال المسلحين يدخلون المنازل وأنت ترى
القناصون قادمون بالفعل، هامس لا يستثمر الكثير
الأمر بضرب الجنود أينما كانوا
جالس لكنه مجرد تنظيم متقطع في رأيي
وهذه قصة أخرى، لا تزال القوة
المقاتلون وطريقة الدخول الإسرائيلية أولاً
بقوى خارقة، حتى في الحفلات
الحمل له ثمن، لا يوجد شيء يمكنني فعله وسأتحمله
لك أن الإصابات معقدة والإصابات خطيرة
ج: مررت بعدة جولات من القتال والحروب
بما أنني أعمل في مستشفى سوروكا بيت
قوة وتعقيد إصابات الحرب
هذا ن